all right hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Freddy
fazbear's pizzaria simulator sorry for
the awkward intro I just didn't know
when I was going live so hello everybody
my name is markiplier as I said before
which is probably not as important as I
think it is welcome welcome welcome
yes so we're gonna be playing five
nights at freddy's well actually
technically this isn't five nights at
freddy's 6
I think it's been made clear by the
developer that this is not 5 1956 but
you might as well call it the six game
in the five nights at Freddy's series
now I'm not a hundred percent on that
that's just something that I heard so hi
hi yes I am a little early today which
is better than being late which is my
typical stance on how I do things so
there's a lot of secrets in this game
that have yet to be discovered
I'm currently in my my old game after
I've already beaten it what I got to do
is I have to start the game over again
and then start it over and over and over
again but to do that I have to die so
buckle up we're gonna we're gonna create
as much noise as possible we're gonna
attract all the animatronics over here
we're gonna wing doodle on a triangle
and fashion symbols hey hey hey boopity
boop I'm printing some Flyers here you
are come kill me who we put in Duty
booty whoa I don't know what's gonna
happen oh that's a weird clown also like
I want to discover oh oh no oh heck oh
that's bad the gas again
now I'm not gonna skip it I don't skip
ads I want my YouTube critics to get
revenue your birthday nah didn't that a
big ol [ __ ] you for you like one of
these so alright so we're gonna be
starting over
lalala this whole thing happening we got
the certificate of completion you can
barely see it here it's it's just under
my webcam over there but we're gonna be
erasing all our progress we're gonna be
starting a new game over again like this
yes I'm sure
cuz we got a lot of work to do it's a
new day yes your time to shine yes it's
time to take your career into your own
hands
yes you've saved money your whole life
great now it's time to put all your eggs
into one basket yeah take a huge gamble
on your future yes gamble that comes
with a 100 percent chance of success in
some cases uh-huh what are we talking
about we're talking about becoming a
fazbear entertainment franchisee Wow
right restaurant ownership and
management roles anyone can do with a
limited degree of success no eyes you're
it's a lot of money to invest but
everyone's doing it and that means it's
safe and lucrative with your initial
investment you'll receive everything you
need to get started including a small
room some tables and electricity Wow but
don't forget about the money you had
leftover after buying your own choice
package ah use it to decorate by a stage
by attractions and animatronics all much
much more okay now let's take a look at
a few things that will help you get
started as a fazbear entertainment
franchisee okay jazz atmosphere ah
making sure your establishment has an
inviting atmosphere is essential to
bringing in new customers okay
entertainment having a lot of
entertainment value in your restaurant
Jesus do I have to okay there we got
can't skip it okay so we already know
all that we've done that before now what
I'm gonna be doing is I'm gonna be going
through different avenues to get to the
secrets in this game there are secrets
in the items that you have to buy but
the number
one way to get you how much cash you had
left over after purchasing your
franchise package great that should be
more than enough no no let's get started
I don't think that's more than enough
are your palms shut up mute voice shut
up shut up okay I'm talking to hope so
this is where things have to be
carefully planned so the first thing
we're learning to do is almost joke but
I need to be able to buy all the things
that I need to get so in order to do
that I need to have enough money so the
first thing I'm gonna be doing is I'm
gonna be getting the various things that
are not risky number one not risky and
not terribly expensive so what I need is
do I actually need in it I don't really
need an animatronic because I can
actually make most of it I'm gonna buy
the cheapest things just the barely
bottom-of-the-barrel cheapest things I
don't care about health and safety as
much as I do about entertainment value
bonus revenue of liability risk we don't
want risk we want no risk cuz we're not
worried about any of that
this has entertainment value that is
health and safety which I guess is good
I guess why
okay this had atmosphere though no
whatever too late okay I'm gonna buy the
single stage I'm gonna get one
animatronic who do I want mr. can do now
I want number one crit number one cried
hell yeah tiny bug sim oh but pan stand
was there or we got fifty five dollars
so we got to be very careful I think the
duck pond has an entertainment value
which is good and I think that's more
important I mean that's got an
entertainment value but that's also got
a lot of risk
this has entertainment value bonus
twenty five
that costs 25 if I get the other one
then buy this one that'd be better than
the duck pond I think yeah so I buy this
the blue and barrel and then I get the
fan spam done a easy-peasy okay so now
we're gonna place these at the stage
things are so yeah the bullet crate
sorry number one crate I apologize all
right salud okay I can't do anything my
play test is okay and I'm I'm gonna take
the sponsorships wait maybe I have no
idea
should I wait should I take the
sponsorships I don't know awesome I got
bored I got I got lewd we'll do that
again oh my god okay anyway so we're
gonna should I take the sponsors because
what I'm planning to do is I'm actually
gonna throw out all of the animatronics
I'm gonna throw them back on the street
I'm gonna just chuck them so I'm just
gonna flip them out the door as soon as
they get in here
ah bonus dollars okay that's important
okay so now that I have bonus dollars I
can now buy something else no I don't
think I can get any of these I need
something else that I can get bonus
revenue from who I would do candy cadet
but I don't know if I can do that what
about the how much was the sponsorship
for 250 that's a good bit that's a good
bit no yes no yes no yes no yes no yes
no yes no yes yes yes no you guys have
no idea I'll take them cuz I mean I can
play with the sponsorships the
sponsorships don't bother me I had every
sponsorship when I beat the game and
that didn't bother me at all but the
money is important because I need to
keep the money flowing so that I can get
I like candy cadet candy cadet is good
so I'm gonna get candy cadet cuz he's
got some stories to tell me they think
just I own the candy cadet come and get
your candy here I have candy all day
every day candy candy candy what happens
if I just don't do anything you're gonna
tell me a story
what happens if I don't get candy is
this a song that you got one you
remember in the end is this your
location when you were when you were the
purple guy and you're walking down the
street and you were like hey not a care
in the world
I'm the purple guy walking down the
street and everybody it's nothing okay I
guess I got addicted and II returned to
candy cadet again and maybe I will tell
you a story that was 2,000 points that's
way more than it gave me last time
hell yeah I mean oh yeah all right
I own the candy cadet come and get your
candy here I have candy all day every
day candy candy candy tell me a story
yeah a story
ah - Kelly cadet again and maybe I will
tell you so it's luck based oh there's a
chance of telling you a story and that
was only 1,000 so it's brand amused it's
random ah least let me do one more cadet
come get your can team your story I have
candy all day every day
tell me your story candy candy everybody
hold on to your hats tell me a story
tell me a story tell me a story
[Music]
dan turned to candy cadet again and
maybe I will tell you a story
wait no the points are going down now oh
maybe oh maybe now he's definitely gonna
tell me a story on the candy cadet come
get your candy here okay I have candy
all day yeah oh you're handy Andy okay
all right
[Music]
huh or 2,000 calorie cadet again and
maybe I will tell you a story so is
random it is Rando it just happened to
be going into pattern okay alright candy
cadet ion the candy cadet come get your
candy here I have candy all day every
day candy candy candy I'm probably gonna
blow all my money on this just to see if
I can get earned not my money but all my
play tokens on this just because I want
to yes return to candy cadet again and
maybe I will tell you a story I want to
try to get these stories cuz I know
there are stories that he tells that is
a fact one of the secrets in this game
is that there are stories no I'm at a
wait oh I own the candy cadet come get
your candy here I have candy all day
every day candy candy candy okay alright
okay alright candy candy candy return to
candy cadet again and maybe I will tell
you a story though this shittiest amount
of candy I've ever seen in my life that
was so stupid
you're so stupid game stupid okay I got
one more try come on give me a story
give me a story baby come high on the
candy I want that story I have K all day
every day candy where's candy candy
alright everybody cross your fingers
everybody cross your fingers
everybody in you're in you're in chat if
there's an emoji of doing this do that
come on Cory
I swear in the sweet glisten story give
it a consistent return to Kelly cadet
again and maybe I will tell you a story
wall that was oh [ __ ] oh you have to use
all ten tokens well I don't have ten
tokens I don't have that I started
without it all right tomorrow I'll spend
all that on that but right now I'm gonna
get more I'm gonna get more stuff I
can't do anything with those yet bonus
revenue is good on that entertainment
value entertainment manager from those
that's good I'm gonna get those bonus
revenue from gumball swivel lands I
can't get any from that but bonus
revenue is good to have in the future
atmosphere oh yeah oh yeah 80 bucks oh
yeah I'm not gonna get those got the
candy cadet do I want to get the stage
which one of these don't have any risk
no risk no risk no risk at all
why did I buy the ones with risk I mean
net bear obviously who wouldn't want net
bear but in my main game leg I can't
believe I just went that way does it's
terribly stupid a lot of things that I
do seem terribly stupid but oh well all
right
mmm whoo that's big atmospheric let me
go for these little lay out let me go
for big atmosphere pong go let me go for
the bit you yeah can I get anything here
I don't know if I can get anything here
oh yeah these are too expensive okay
these are just out of my price range
sure the German brothers the fruit punch
clown in the lemonade clown you know the
one thing you can say about Scott
Cawthon the developer of this game and
all the five nights at freddys things is
uh man he has an imagination of
connecting things that you would never
think to be connected like a fruit punch
clown that scares patrons and is pitched
in German like this just those are just
elements
oh also bonus very very important pay
attention the name of this little
animatronic here
his name is hell p the names helping oh
yeah
that name is help e that's help you
right there that's so cute I'm so glad I
made the first thumbnail featuring LP
because I knew I knew help he was gonna
be like the best of this one anyway so
what I can do is I don't have enough
space to place those down let me see how
I'm working with space of what I got
right now
Oh Oh gumball so Lance isn't a space
thing all these speakers and lights for
a number one great freaking party for
number one great okay so I got floor
space which means that I can indeed get
more stuff I don't think there's
anything else here to get would there be
sanitation sedation duck pond that can
do that that's pretty cheap and bonus
revenue yeah yeah I'll do that
why not and Stan number one crow number
one crime I'd like to think it's tiny
bugs stem up there it's the only
featuring tiny bug said okay ah
got again I got 300 left I can't there's
no point in getting a stage because it
doesn't add anything to number one crate
so why would I do that but I could get
the arcade cabinet and I could place
that down yeah let me do that I can't
play it right now but it's definitely
gonna be better for the first night if I
put that down and then more patrons are
gonna want to be here okay duck pond and
that and then I'm gonna add a coin slot
- yeah coin slot - nice all right okay
all right I think that's good enough so
it's going to our first night there
shouldn't be any animatronics here there
could be or restaurant is now officially
open so that doesn't mean your job is
finished however you have a lot of work
to do while patrons eat their pizza in
the other room
Wow from your terminal you have supplies
to buy papers to print and repairs to
make Wow
once you've taken care of all the items
on your to-do list
why money for supplies and repairs comes
out of petty cash so don't worry about
it coming out of your pocket okay got
you covered the only money you have to
worry about is if you choose to upgrade
any of the equipment in your office
right now onto other matters something
to be aware of is that the ventilation
system and your terminal are highly loud
and may prevent you from hearing things
in adjoining air vents AHA that won't be
a problem if there is nothing in the
vents however if you feel that something
might be in the vents you have a few
tools at your disposal to protect
yourself you can shut off your terminal
and the ventilation system at any time
now decrease the amount of attention you
are drawing today I'm not going to do
that also shining your life directly
into a vent will most likely prevent
anything from jumping out now you also
have three tools available from the
terminal itself oh here's a motion
detector an audio decoy and a secondary
ventilation unit keep in mind however
that you can only have one of these
active at any given time Wow now get to
it huh simply log off when you've
completed your tasks for the day man you
can go get some coffee
I love coffee actually I don't drink
coffee but I've got all this on the back
so there if I play this right there
should be no animatronics at all that's
the idea
there should be no animatronics at all
right that's the idea so once I get this
underway and once I'm able to get this
get alt like I'm gonna get the story out
of candy cadet why was the light
flickering there but once I get the
story out of candy cadet in the next one
there's also the the minigames in the
game itself all the different products
all the different things in there they
have different things that have secrets
in them the arcade cabinets have secret
modes for the games like the the various
different things that uh like the the
the puppet that you can actually buy you
can buy the puppet if you get enough
money and the only way that you're gonna
get enough money is if you make this
place profitable as all hell and you got
to do that you like you got to do it to
the extreme so I'm gonna do it
to the extreme if I can I don't know if
I can well we'll see place bulbs come on
I want to go and dunzo I'm out of your
job it looks like you're getting the
hang of this that's me now let's just
focus on getting you through your first
week hey yeah it's a big party here
Saturday
oh yeah should view that day as your
ultimate test oh I will I get through
Saturday uh-huh I've proven you're oh
yeah as the successful entrepreneur that
we all know you can be oh I know I am oh
I know oh I know trust me excuse me I
know I'm amazing can you just shut up
and go away I'm absolutely amazed
congratulations on completing your first
day however your job isn't over just yet
ah there is another aspect to your end
of day routine and that is inspecting
and salvaging nope
throw it back throw it back shut it out
there just start them all to be in one
place anyway so you son of a [ __ ]
whoops just out here get the Ricky Audi
turned away
that's stupid yeah yeah no lawsuits baby
no lawsuits why would there be lawsuits
there's a safe and wonderful place no
lawsuits all right so but that's not
where we're gonna get most of our money
I know for a fact and I'm gonna be
looking at candy Coderre right here I'm
gonna spend all ten of my tokens on
candy cadet because I'm gonna get this
story 100% I am is candy cadet come and
get your candy here I have candy all day
every day candy candy - candy cadet
again amazing I will tell you a story
I'm spending all 10 tokens on this son
of a [ __ ] I'm not gonna miss out on it
it's gonna happen and I'm gonna get all
that candy money from it
come get your candy here I'm here I have
candy all day every day candy candy
candy yep
BAM okay return to candy cadet again and
maybe I will tell you a story candy
candy candy candy kid I just look at
chances candy candy candy candy candy
candy candy
yes please more candy candy cadet please
[Music]
- candy cadet again
and maybe I will tell you a story about
you are a sack of [ __ ] and you give me a
goddamn story already
give it to me yes get your candy here oh
I have candy all day
wow really no way that's a lot of candy
I don't know if I can handle that candy
mr. Cadell - candy cadets again and
maybe I will tell you a story
someone just stopped in there is someone
just joined the stream in the candy
smooth just like a lot of questions like
of all the people in the stream like if
you just join in randomly and everyone
shout in candy at the top of the long
she's gonna look like alright well this
is not the place for me I went to that
weird part of YouTube oh well I'm just
gonna back away slowly from this
endeavor alright see you tomorrow or
whatever your name actually is Bob
return eternity cadets again alright
candy can suck my candy I don't want to
suck your candy it's annoying I don't
know what about what about this could be
annoying what what in the world could
possibly be annoying about Chad just
exploding candy out of their ass alright
Bob that's a good kid and maybe I will
tell you a story
[Music]
mm-hmm all right once they if he does
tell the story everybody's got a quiet
down real quick but we've got four more
tokens to spend on the sandy cadet come
and get your candy here yes I have candy
all day every day
Wow candy Wow okay all right ready
I don't know how there's gonna go to
candy cadet again and maybe I will tell
you a story
no what is happening what's this okay
spread the candy to the other areas of
the internet just go like on Twitter and
just start spamming at me just candy
candy candy like confuse everybody get
in the candy hash tag and just blow it
up right now just have nobody know
everyone's having a lovely day like
Nestle Corporation is is talking about
hash tag candy but their board meeting
and also insert yourself into their
conversation and a little tell you a
story yeah we got two more tokens two
more tokens we got this I don't know if
we can do this
guys this is I am really difficult come
get your candy here come on candy please
candy never okay all right hold onto
your horses everybody there's gonna be a
wall right return to candy cadet again
and maybe I will tell you a story
everybody get hashtag candy trending
please that's what I need I need it all
right here we go
I am the candy cadet you better freaking
tell me your story if you don't tell me
a story of candy will be so many candy
come on Andy give me Andy
give me give me that sweet candy baby
returned to candy cadet again and maybe
I will tell you a story budget what you
guys promised me then if I did ten
tokens on that [ __ ] Oh was I supposed
to light insert the tokens into his
[ __ ] like what was that all about
Jesus you guys ruined me all right fine
then fine fine
oh thank you everybody wow you guys are
so helpful damn it guys you guys just
shut candy down shut it all down
shut the candy down Candy's canceled
everything is canceled Candy's just
[ __ ] and everybody know it
it's the caller it's the caller what
color am I going for that all good
caller all right anyway what else was I
doing I need to get new stuff
okay that's risky now oh that's good
okay that's possibility I can get the
fruit punch clown be on the jukebox
medical station Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow no I'm not gonna do it not gonna do
it I'm gonna do it okay all these
animals have a little bit of risk do
them okay so I'm gonna get this guy cuz
that's a lot of bonus revenue and that's
probably not a floor placeable as far as
I remember and I'm gonna get this guy
because he is a floor placeable
but he's got a lot of bonus revenue okay
yeah box up okay so you go right there
oh what a fun place for the whole family
oh I need the I wait you go right here
yeah no wait you go hey I got this I got
this
you go right there you go right there
hey you go right there okay so I got 470
more dollars I need to spend every
single penny on it the good stuff let's
see I probably should also get some
health and safety stuff like this thing
that's probably important all right I
don't think there's anything on the
first thing what else could the fruity
mace I think that's all for the like
easily placeable stuff wait why was
candy condemned what the hell withheld
liability risk of three that's that all
markdown okay is fine I don't want that
it's fine it's fine
I don't want any risk here but yeah I'm
wondering look cuz this is marked down
but it doesn't have any liability risk
in it
I still don't trust it I just I still
don't trust the man I still don't trust
that it's I'm not right about that okay
instead of doing anything else I'm
actually gonna add coin slots to the
things I already
like okay so that's a little more bonus
revenue there we got a little more bonus
revenue here to do it okay anyway so
we're good for oh I can actually add one
more oh that's right cuz it increased
the the doodle daddle right okay sweet
okay so we got that everything's good so
far we're out of tokens we've got a lot
of good stuff going on here so if we
yeah so the candy could dead no no no
about that but I'm gonna yeah liability
risk is for lawsuits not necessarily the
animatronics if you buy a markdown thing
it's gonna be bad okay so I have a funny
okay so anyway I'm gonna carry on next
time I don't know if I'm gonna keep
going on candy cadet but something tells
me candy cadet is gonna give up with k2
kinetic needs we're gonna make this
candy cadets dream okay this should
still be nobody in here I there
shouldn't be anybody in here I don't
know why there would be shouldn't be it
wouldn't be anybody in here right right
there's there's no way right
leftie oh by the way also secret lefty
inside lefty is the puppet as far as
I've heard inside lefty is actually like
if you look at one of the rare screens
with lefty on it that people sometimes
get after they die or like they see a
picture of the animatronics sitting
outside of the pizzeria you can actually
see in one of the shoulder joints is the
striped pattern of the puppets arm going
down into the frame of the animatronic
like it does exist there and it is there
and it's super creepy to think about
because also in that rare screen is a
poster of the puppet just like looking
mad as all hell staring down at you so
pretty uh pretty creepy and I don't know
what that I don't know what the actual
like what they actually Laura that
because I don't know who lefty is but
also the fun thing about this is like
there's a bunch of animatronics here
that are just barely offshoots of the
various main animatronics and what it
kind of does I don't know if this was
ever official it's probably not official
but it does lend some credence to all of
the fan made five nights at Freddy's
games it explains why there are so many
different versions of it all existing in
the same universe now I'm not saying
that's a hundred percent cannon but you
know like five nights at candy's like
five nights at UM at the krusty krab of
all things like it's all offshoots of
these because fazbear entertainment
allows people the franchisor like what
we're doing right now all these other
animatronics in here they may have been
infront aft world or various other
places but these other locations that
exists only in fan-made games can
sometimes be cannon under this premise
and this idea so that's a thing that can
happen I'm not a hundred percent sure
about it but it's a thing so no no can I
Slurpee out of this one
also he said in the patch notes lately
there was something else about there's a
green man by a door and his hitbox got
increased to be bigger I have no idea
what that is the green man by the door
which doesn't make any sense to me at
all but by the lemonade Club I was done
fizz time pop soda get out of here all
right I'm out of here
so should I just keep going for should I
just keep going for candy cadet I don't
wanna I don't wanna look good god uh-oh
who's this for you is an animatronic
found in the back alley wow we are
unsure of the torah' jhin's I don't see
it either you have to complete the main
Chuck that bad boy back up with me Alan
Saturday you want them all to be in one
place okay all right oh no no first time
story what about it racing game yeah I'm
gonna get to the racing game I will get
there do not worry come on more I need
more money than that any more money all
right so we've got candy cadet here
should we should we go candy should we
go 100 percent candy I do want oh I do
want that sweet delicious candy right
bye bubble gum station all right it's
gonna be the one it's gonna be the one
I'm gonna clean the possum first up get
that nice polish there oh wow wow yes
your candy here all right I have candy
all day every day
candy Oh candy what color am I going for
everybody shouted out at the top of your
lungs it's time for candy
- purple purple return - candy cadet
again and maybe I will tell you a story
no all right okay I'm just going by the
color of the top button on the top of
them story I'm gonna get these goddamn
stories if there's the last thing I do
that
come get your candy here I have candy
all day every day candy candy candy
[Music]
Green Green Green Green Green return to
candy cadet again and maybe I will
yellow purple blue orange don't just
shout out random colors that doesn't
help anybody candy purple red red red
red red blue blue red blue blue it's a
boy I offered it come get your candy
here I have candy all day every day
candy orange orange I'm getting 1250
every single time to tell you a story
what does that even mean I'm get I'm
getting 12 in 12 50 points every time
and I'm hitting it on different colors
damn you damn you candy cuber give me
the goddamn story on the candy red okay
I'm gonna give red black there's no
black I have can there's no black
anywhere I mean the black on the arm
candy there's no black color being shown
at me that make any sense
this red
dear mentor Kelly cadet again and maybe
I will tell can tackle this it's not a
jackal jackal it's a jackal penguin
that's not that's not even related blue
bow jackal blitz blitz was that you can
be here I have candy press f4 red every
day
candy candy candy cadet I'm gonna get
this goddamn candy cadet how much just
wait I'm gonna wait oh wait I'm gonna
wait
[Music]
I'm gonna wait because I'm gonna see
the song is changing it's still going
oh damn it it just looped over again
[Music]
return me to candy cadet again and maybe
I'm gonna I'm gonna just candy I you see
this this this claw hand I'm gonna dig
this into your chest and pull out your
heart all your heart of candy I'm gonna
get me some goddamn story Katie can dead
that's all I gotta say about this
everything candy candy okay Jim I don't
think Jim's a caller I mean I wouldn't
be surprised if Jim all the gyms of the
rainbow like if it's gonna happen but
hang on everybody hold onto your hats
and we'll keep the candy train going
[Music]
again and maybe I will tell you a story
it's got to be totally randomized right
it's got to be completely randomized
whether that randomization is based on
anything that I can control that I don't
know but here I have handled a candy
candy don't see a pink I mean I kind of
see a pink but it's Kelly cadet again
and maybe I wouldn't can't see to blow
this I can't the B does nothing what
would the B do the B does nothing to
this
I can't after all that I can't have to
pay my respects to it can't do nothing
nothing I am a candy cat that yes your
candy here I have candy all day every
day maybe I will tell you a story it
changed like Scott updated the game and
it changed candy could
[Music]
I don't like out sometimes just pauses
there that's very disconcerting but he
changed there because sometimes before
it was like incremental increasing
numbers of handing pointed but now it's
all like weird and different okay hey
return to koneko diameter maybe I will s
to slap this [ __ ] I don't know that's to
to be to backhand this [ __ ] out of
bamboo last one last token we got we got
this fuel can be here we got this the
old day every day every day every day
every day we got candy every day if you
just believe in the candy we're gonna
start the Church of candy here who could
have believed in the candy we got the
the holy candy Bible we got it it's got
to believe guys we're gonna start a cult
the cult of candy we're gonna move out
into the middle of desert I'm gonna buy
a big compound we're all gonna live
there together as one and it's the name
of candy - candy cadet again and maybe I
will tell you a story
alright we're still gonna go on the
desert but there's more of an exiled
type thing now we're gonna be get a
build a big compound there together who
wouldn't want that
I'm I need more money I need to get like
exponentially more money Oh No ah you're
a liability risk man these are so
expensive it's so expensive oh she's got
the liability risk on that thing
god I can't afford it but that's
hilarious
yeah I need to get the security puppet
eventually which is totally great great
thing wasn't that in another game - that
was a little security puppet I can't
remember
lefty are a good buddy lefty lefty okay
music man L chip these these guys are
great because they have pickles I bought
the pickles why can't I have the pickles
what can I have the pickles
oh all right I don't that good God I
don't like that guy all right anyway I
want to figure out how to get the
pickles - that's gonna be definitely a
thing that's gonna be happening but we
need to buy some more reasonable
purchases I guess whatever well all
right I'm gonna get I'm gonna get this
so I can have more animatronics I mean I
know I just need number one crate and
frankly I'm tempted to only just buy
number one crate but at the same time
the funny feeling that I probably should
go for something a little more God is
there really nothing else to get there
really nothing else to get that's yeah I
really got to go for the animatronics
all right I guess I gotta go there for
the animatronics let's buy this thing
because everything else is a huge
liability risk a hill and I mean huge
reliability risk
I do want to get the Rockets but it
don't want any risk
I want no risk got you all risky I like
it stop being risky all right we need we
need some friends for Dumbo and crate
all right you're good happy frog oh
you're the happiest frog mr. hippo not
that guy in pig patch all right pig
patch mr. hippo happy frog all right
cool cool cool cool
number one crate gets the limelight in
the singers position we got happy Frog
backup vocals mr. hippo no vocals and
banjo pig yeah oh yeah that's the good
stuff
all right so that we got that that's
good that's great nice we gotta get more
oh we got exotic cupcakes I don't think
exotic cupcakes is this thing that we
can get here I like your candor but I
just don't think that's possible
what else we got no no I do like the
latter Tower but no no I like that a lot
but no what if I put some safety straps
on it what if I put some if I put some
safety straps on that bad boy it won't
have no risk right yeah that's true
right I'm not right there a better way
to go about that anything else I can get
bloom dirt no I can't get nothing else
can't even get that yeah yeah okay yeah
exotic butters they aren't a thing in
this game nother thing it's pickles oh
my gosh pickles I can't even have them
look at this I'm gonna put some safety
straps on this bad boy you get out of
here stupid balloons this oh yeah that's
good safety strap no risk playing pause
that's like yeah a coin talk to
everything clean faucet yeah that's a
good chef
it can cause that pause that cause that
is there anything else
atmospheric that I can get I've got
fifty 1400 I guess I could upgrade to a
larger floorplan
let's do that then I can get the most
amount of stuff on the ground including
this guy slide
oh that paid for itself alright anything
else I can get put on the ground here I
get these boots on the ground I can put
a safety strap on that that's always
good everybody loves that everybody
loves that no it really isn't much else
no I can't afford that you know I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna buy this I'm
gonna put some safety straps on this
ball every time I think of this is an
actual ball minimally yeah I remember
that's terrible this is terrible this is
a horrible irresponsible of me all right
so we got no risk still no risk go way
better all right we're gonna do this all
right now for another uneventful night
maybe let's see about that all right
I don't know if we should go for candy
again next time
I want those pickles so I've won the
pickle I want him I want the breakfast
I bought the pickles want them anyway
all right so we're carrying on here so
one things the other didn't know about
this game is it's it's it's really
interesting how conclusive it was at the
end of it I had like time to like look
up other people's theories on it other
people talking about it but the thing
about it was the end of this game when
he played through it it was super
unbelievably conclusive like it was very
much this is what happened we are
redeeming for our sins we are playing
the price for what we've done we believe
in we believe in atoning for past
mistakes like that whole thing and it
was very obvious because if the designs
may be different and I don't know if the
designs are like a super choice or or
like because fundamentally like the
animatronics are different even
spring-trap especially is fundamentally
different you shouldn't
[Music]
there shouldn't be anyone in here there
should be no one
yeah there's no one there's no one in
here I don't know what that was
there's no one in here yeah okay but it
was definitive right it was very very
clear of what it was talking about it
was done and it was like it was not
there so there must be you know
there's gotta be something to that so
I'm not a hundred percent sure but I'm
pretty sure that the ending of this game
was supposed to be kind of like a come
full circle
wrapping up everything like it had an
overlay of the first five nights at
Freddy's game environment
god damn it Marty get out of here stupid
[ __ ] all right so it's gotta be
something else before that there's got
to be right there's got to be something
else anyway so I don't know what other
secrets we're gonna discover out of like
I want the frickin stories that's all I
want right now I just want stories but
it looks like we may not get those
because of the Ditka tree that it's all
about but there is repeatable things
that I can get in the arcade cabinet so
the next time we go out in the main area
I'm gonna get the arcade cabinets and
try to do those things because those are
interesting Easter eggs I know there's
multiple endings I I do know there's
multiple endings and actually I'm
probably on pace to get one of the ones
which is probably gonna be one of the
bad endings but there are multiple
endings I think there's a total of four
five maybe are there five endings maybe
even six I have no idea there's
different certificates that you can get
across the board for these things so I'm
gonna try to get all the certificates in
this live stream but I don't know if I'm
able to do it because number one it just
takes a lot of time to get through this
game over and over and over again but
hey we got time right then we got
nothing but time all right let's log off
here all right okay thank you can you
please move on all right
before you is an animatronic found in
the back alley no we are unsure of its
origins it is your job to complete the
maintenance checklist before claiming it
and salvage yeah if you choose to you
can throw it back into the alley where
you found it and forfeit payment please
make your choice now
yeah but throw it back OOP there goes so
yeah don't forget Saturday you want them
all to be in one place now I realize
that prompt says don't forget Saturday
you want them all to be in one place
they're not talking about the guests
they're talking about the animatronics
the animatronics hey no one was turned
away that's awesome the animatronics
need to all be in one place that's why
the ending hell yeah hell yeah I'm such
a happy and safe place everybody loves
to be here all right I'm not gonna go
for candy I'm not it's just I'm not
gonna do it I'm gonna do the uh the
motorists Easter Egg so I believe it's
on the last lap I don't know what the
last lap is but I don't even know if I I
may not have left facin I actually I
actually did play this in in the in my
main series of it but I don't remember
if I left it in the actual game
because I might have cut it out because
I didn't think anything of it I didn't
get the Easter egg in this I was playing
it because I was playing it so I'm
pretty sure in the third lap
not this one to the third
my bullet health skills are working for
me I'm pretty sure so what I need to do
is I need to hit Q slow down go over
here or maybe it's the fourth lap I
don't know if there's a fourth flapper
[Music]
come on where are you oh it's maybe the
fourth level boom
you go forth lab
[Music]
there it is their desserts yes this
yeah
[Music]
yeah so I don't know what this means is
the thing I'm not 100% sure what it
means to be driving around here Oh
Junior's maybe it was that what they
meant by the Green Man
hey hey hey
okay leave now we go back that seems
pretty final I'm gonna go back to I'm
gonna go back to the the bar juniors I'm
gonna go to juniors I'm uh come on hang
out at the bar for a bit I'm pretty sure
that's a bar all right ask me what a
little bit too deep beneath anybody do
no good
come on you know you can't be here don't
make this more difficult than it has I
don't know what you're talking about all
right
anyway sure okay I can't be I don't know
what that's talking about but I don't
know I'm not welcome I'm a pretty jovial
guy I'm practically Santa Claus I'm so
happy and fun to be around and awesome
and cool again okay nah not the house go
back okay all right okay all right and
there's something else there's something
else here there's some Oh secret
let's see okay all right okay go back
and going back guys I'm going back all
right hang on there's something to some
secret here so some secret here in the
back of the parking lot maybe somewhere
around here background back can't go
back here all right okay I think you
guys might just be utterly confused cuz
this is what happens when there's so
many people in chat when when someone
says go back they don't know like I have
no idea when you mean go back to so yeah
I explore in the house well I was going
to the house telling me I was going
[Laughter]
alright guys hush down start shouting
candy again you guys just need here put
your binky back in just here you just
shout candy it's alright just go about
candy I got this let me take care of
this I got this it's good yeah yeah
shout candy go candy candy spam candy
candy candy candy start hashtag candy go
it again I got this oh my god
good plumb the depths of this like God
you missed the house what this house
that was obviously here at the end of
the road and the obviously final thing
so obviously I had to go check to see if
there was anything else because I'm
thorough
what was that candy all right candy
candy that's all Oh
[Music]
yeah
war broken window interesting I'm just
making a full loop around the house you
got to cover all the bases before you
commit to a decision
whoo trash cans why do I have three why
do I have so much trash okay all right
so I'm going to the back window I've
committed to this because I've explored
and I'm not paying attention to you
shouting candy yeah yeah candy candy
candy candy candy wait Oh can't go back
here what the hell was even the point of
this futile exercise seems like that's
it so I'm gonna go to the front door
maybe I bet it'll be something like the
front door Oh tell me to go to the back
look something like that it's usually
how these things go when he tried to
actually be some sort of sneaky about
something all right what do we got here
hey leave him alone tonight he had a
rough day
okay
I told you not to close your door well I
guess it is my house you can't ignore me
like that well I guess you can't ignore
me like that oh I was gonna try to go
out around open da door oh boy I'll find
my way off see I'll find a way in from
outside that see it's the thing that I
did too early
it's just like surprised whoever's in
that run why are you doing what are you
doing in here you being secretive that's
my house
alright okay hello well I'm trying to
find a way in from an old whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
are there footprints here but those are
not human footprints right there you see
what I'm seeing
right in front of me those are
animatronic footprints or some large
animal ran off to that place again he'll
be sorry when he gets back oh oh I guess
we're done okay all right well anyway
I'm gonna play this one now
[Music]
we're the slug I need a slug can't
believe I said that in my mind but I
need a slug I don't like you I think the
secret in this one is you have to just
like number one you have to win we have
to win like on the first try or
something got it
all right I'm super fast first should I
lost my magnetism damn it I ran out well
I've got so much speed I just man I
wasted the magnet yeah probably whoo
I've never moved this fast before in my
life and I love some down there too oh
geez god damn it of course I did this
yeah because the question here sorry I'm
concentrating with the question here is
who is this little girl and why is she
here and how do I get up there
today of course why did I leave things
behind like this I'm such a tool it's
our way down there no [ __ ]
please tell me please send a yes oh damn
it oh god of course of course of course
ah geez no oh oh no oh no I'm so boned
up so bummed I'm so bummed
oh wait wait wait wait wait oh how do I
get that one oh god damn it
oh I've really boned myself I don't
think I'm gonna be able to get this god
damn it damn it and damn you damn it and
oh wait where do you even go for that go
away oh I've got like five left and I've
really screwed myself oh god damn it cuz
I don't think I think you have to get it
all right you know what I must say out
of that rabbit hello I rabbit oh god
damn it I think you have to get it I
think you have to get it on your first
token and I just ah you have to win
three times that's it okay wait
it's just the three time when I'm gonna
try it again cuz I got plenty of tokens
okay cuz I can do this I just got that I
just got it in the wrong order that's
all I did
[Music]
well apparently I got a hold on it
nothing
there we go some speed wall school and
mega all right
go go go go go go ah [ __ ] I forgot about
that
god dammit god dammit dammit okay I got
this
this one's gonna be a doozy to get but I
got this guy's get the candy train going
I gotta concentrate on this I can't
exactly talk in the moment - you have to
talk for me please help me out
get the candy going this is the same map
out of way this is the same oh I almost
got stuck in that wall I think I've got
plenty of magnet time give me a bit more
magnetism the only thing you really need
is the magnetism because you don't have
to go to every little corner to try to
find absolu that's sherry with a bone to
me but I don't think there's any more
where is more or more Mormon god damn it
god damn it damn it damn it I don't know
why I don't know what is so hard is not
that hard and it's not that hard I got
this
I got this I got this I got this I think
the map wait is the map the same no
matter what I think the map is the same
no matter what it's just that where you
start in the map that's what changes
okay that's helpful [ __ ] I need to get
the magnetism before I get the slug I
can't believe I said those words but
there we are I gotta go all the way
around don't I I gotta go the long way
around don't I because I hate ya just
apparently I hate being good at games
how bad I am oh man I wish for one day I
could just like not do that like look at
myself and be like I'll make today the
day that I'm not gonna suck games but I
can't do that cuz it's terrible to run
through no matter what I do okay well
yeah that was a dead end that I just ran
into that's great yes okay I think I've
got just enough time to be able to smash
this bad boy out here and its second now
[Music]
yes yes yes
god damnit of course 60 seconds and a
lot of speed I got to do this manually
but I think I got this amazing amazing
that's me that's the definition of me I
gotta win that like three times is that
what it is
whoa what is this
ah that's those legless pittman sit oh
god yep that's legless kitties sitting
in a full of blood Oh God
some kind of legless Pikachu happening
uh well that's not good not good okay
all right well this is mildly depressing
okay well I can't even hello I haven't
even been able to get to a single
powerup I just want to get to that where
do I get that one this is one of the
magnet and the speed would speed would
be nice but barely
everything's just tantalizingly far away
all right well I'm not gonna be able to
win this one cuz I got nothing it's just
giving me access to a whole lot of dick
uh how about this is the best I can do
yep there we go that's good stuff
alright well it's not gonna matter
wolf slug that's there we go there we go
now again now we're getting and now
we're getting it we may be able to pull
this back from the brink but I'm not
armed since you're that's okay I don't
know how but we managed to pull that out
of our asses all right whatever
oh damn and I left things in weird
places Oh things are super blurry I
don't know why okay I think I got
everything over here so I just need to
go over to that one pocket I don't know
if I have enough time to do that though
Oh God cuz I have no idea where no that
wasn't everything course it wasn't an
amount of magnetism oh boy in 20 seconds
oh boy is that it please tell me that's
not like the one last thing here or
please tell me that is the one last
thing because I'm about to get that why
well I never I can't believe you would
do that to me here we'll go again okay
they're good it's the horrified don't go
that way that was the way they got me in
trouble before go for the magnetism even
better
[Music]
got all these go for the magnetism next
best face he's gonna make a big loop
around the outsides give me that slow
yeah yeah that's tough good stuff good
stuff TM of course I'm in this nebulous
area where I can't actually get what I
need to get but I'm a nail this to the
wall I don't need the magnet to be able
to succeed I guess all right okay three
more tokens we got this okay oh yeah oh
wow okay all right that's that's awful
wow that is that is every kind of
horrible oh oh I can't get that
apparently Oh No nose nose bead for me
oh hey springy Travie behind me standing
there oh yeah that's that's not good
okay well alright well hoof okay
well no speed for me definitely no speed
okay no speed definitely okay well Wow
I don't like the way I track their blood
[Music]
yay yay yay yeah we're having fun here
oh boy oh boy well that's us no good
ah nothing like some wacky wart paste to
get rid of those warts of that
experience from my brain I'm so happy
about that
thank you wacky wart paste for being
there for me
can i play test this oh the boss
you the boss pizza you are you can't
beat me I am the world's greatest buffer
what are there some secrets of this
minigame - it's gotta be right
we're gonna push him back real hard now
we're going so well for me I wasn't
paying attention
oh he's very disappointed hey I gotta do
that again I gotta do that again I got
one more token I'm gonna make this
I wasn't huh I got this I'm really good
at shmups guys shut up I am I swear I am
just love the way hope he looks when
he's having fun the help is just a
cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
[Music]
Oh Nelly oh my god oh my god
Oh what's this oh the boss pizza haha
not gonna be
not gonna be a problem if he doesn't
actually aim for me this seems pretty
easy very simple that's it
I wanted more oh man is there is there
like a easter egg in that one
do you guys know is there an easter egg
in that one let me know yeah I know I
want pizza - now for some reason I
really want some pizza but is there any
is there uh is there is there any easter
egg in that particular one it's so real
the boss pizza kingdom are kinda in a
way yeah i guess alright peace of
supreme guns nothing no I don't know it
gets harder every time you win oh maybe
that is it maybe I can go back to that
next time ooh I'll do that no secret but
okay alright I might go back to that
okay so I got eight thousand five
hundred I need to make more money that's
nice
gravity vortex I want that really badly
but something tells me I probably
shouldn't oh this guy's so good
Orvil elephant prize king there's a lot
of bonus revenue out of something ooh
but I could save up and get the security
puppet oh I could do that I want the big
I mean I'm gonna get I'll be able to get
the puppet next time anyway so I might
as well get well I wouldn't be able to
do anything from the prize Kingdom today
but he will get me more money next time
so I'm gonna get the prize King just
because it's a lot of bonus revenue and
I have a spot for him
okay boss what a slot on that no risk
okay all right we're good to go
all right let's get through the next one
there still shouldn't be any
animatronics as far as I know you
shouldn't be
I'll get the puppet next time next day
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow go on okay
all right
no don't do that scary anybody here yeah
no Easter Egg yeah I know there's no
Easter Egg I will get the puppet I will
get the puppet I'm pretty sure next time
around with the next sponsorship that
I'm gonna get the next sponsorship is
like $5,000 I'm gonna be able to get
that and then I'll get a lot more
revenue from tonight and I'm pretty sure
I'll be able to get the security puppet
for tomorrow I'm not sure what effect
that's gonna happen I'm gonna have yeah
get out of here all right don't have
that ah they will kill you in there I
don't know get the prize King I already
get the prize game there's a lot of
balls yeah I kind of got that Oh God I
got it I got it I got it I got it shut
up
wacky war face I don't care you
interrupting me Mary Craig yeah it's not
even worth getting you I'm not gonna
waste the money on the equipment yeah
why would I do that
get the pickles I want to get the
pickles I want to I want to I want to
very badly I want to badly but it won't
let me off this time shut up
ah all right I got this how do they make
art of lefty if lefty isn't here yet you
know who made all this art what kind of
kids were doing this cuz this is is it
not good not good at all for tokens for
puppet okay all right I'll save for
tokens for puppet I'll save I'll save up
I'll save it alt f4 to win okay
all right well here we go all right it
and you soften f2 where do you see if an
f2 oh and the background of the one that
I just the thumbnail here yeah I did
that I like to use the fat snap to
office I still say I still safe enough
to was the best five nights at Freddy's
game I mean the original will always
hold that place in my heart for the
story wise but as far as like mechanics
mystery intrigue difficulty like I gotta
go with five nights at Freddy's - there
was nothing that was more intricately
designed and also a good sequel to the
first one like it really set the pace
like five nights at Freddy's one was
really good but if five nights at
Freddy's 2 wasn't as good as it was then
the series wouldn't be lasting as long
as it is even today like there's just so
much there yeah it's just it's always
gonna held a special place in my heart
for all of that I've already done the
midnight racers and I've done the fruity
thing the fruit maze of death that that
was I didn't beat it but I don't think
you can beat it last time I'm pretty
sure you cannot beat that last round
because if it doesn't give you the
power-ups and there's just no way to do
it like you don't have enough time yeah
I'll get there I'll get there I have to
is garbage how dare you how dare you how
dare you if an app three I don't know
fine a three I didn't like it as much I
mean it was good it was interesting
mechanics but I don't know it was kind
of like a bait and switch because it was
supposed to be like this ended to
something and yet it didn't didn't feel
like it before you is an animatronic
found in the back alley we are unsure of
its origins ensures your job to complete
the maintenance check
salvaged this is what I didn't see you
do you can throw it back into the alley
where you found it
payment please make your choice now no
I'm gonna throw it back
this is Lefty I didn't realize that
lefty was gonna be the last day I'm a
tronic here ah because remember he's I
got the sign who said I've already
inside to be in one place yep yep yeah
five nice sister location no sister
location was an amazing gunfire that's a
pretty name and it was great because it
was such a departure from the typical
five nights at Freddy's stuff and I like
that I really like that unique mechanics
for almost every encounter and just it
was more like the gameplay fit the story
which I liked a lot I don't know if he
was like the best thing in the world but
it was my favorite thing okay all right
oh no are we gonna have enough yeah
we're gonna have enough if I do the
plate token stuff all right
Lally's lollies got that lolis lollies
okay prize cake kind of want to test the
prize king let's see what the prize King
is all about
yeah I don't like that I like that I
don't wanna I don't want to grab your
ball they do a few more times on that
one oh I don't like this very clearly
it's very clearly very dick like it's
very clearly oh that's not not good all
right here we go prize king well this is
disappointing this is very sad is very
sad okay here we go I'm ready go
damn it what the hell is with the prize
king what's with the prize king what
this [ __ ] this is [ __ ] give me
something prize King I'm sure [ __ ] you -
[ __ ] you prize gang just [ __ ] you
can take your prizes you can shove them
up your ass that's all you can do
come on are you second [ __ ] prize cake
what are you going with your life go
what do not even like me you know who I
am do know how much I scream on the
internet I'll scream of you yeah I'm
doing it right now but yeah I can scream
louder oh I can oh oh oh you sack of
[ __ ] oh you're gonna be like this huh
alright well do can play this game of
persistency I'm gonna get you imma shove
my whole foot how much she's got she's
normally $71,000 I made out like a
bandit oh holy Shi look at her sassiness
oh she looks so good I gotta put her in
a normal spot she's normally in this
spot ah look at her look at her yeah
yeah can I get the pickles now can I get
the pickles gonna get the pickles damn
it
Curnow get the pickles is that like a
prize from prize king you can get the
pickles from the prize king is that what
you can do
okay all right I see Otis no I'm not
getting rid of number one crate look at
her look at her she's so good I got her
Wow guys I'm really proud of myself if I
did nothing else with the rest of my
life I'm really happy that I gambled all
my money away to get funding chica who's
probably gonna kill me well it hurts you
so sassy got him in love I'm in love I'm
in love I'm in love guys guys this is it
I'm in love I'm in love oh do you think
she likes candy kind of [ __ ] she likes
candy
all right I got a try I'm in I'm in a
very tight spot because I think this
might be the last night and I don't have
enough money for the security puppet
which was a grave mistake on my part so
I should save my money but maybe you
guys said that this gets harder so I
want to see cuz then I can get a lot of
points if I can get like stupid amount
of points then maybe give me the hardest
one give me a hard yes more more give me
more give me more give me please I want
points I can take this difficult game in
the world I can do it I'm gonna give me
difficulty please
because I can do it
it's the minimal amount of points I have
buy everything for pickles wide how in
the world are you supposed to be able to
get enough money to buy absolutely
everything oh this is a problem ah I
wasn't I was looking at Chet doesn't my
bed I could do that I wasn't paying
attention
yeah I was gonna oh I bet egg baby has a
secret oh I understand eggs baby there's
anything that has a secret it's gotta be
egg baby
back stay back stay got a really shove
him in no no no you get away get away
get away get away get away get away get
away get away
no wait get away get away get away get
away get away I think this is a little
bit more difficult I'm not mistaken this
does seem just to be a hair more
difficult which I like I want all the
sweet points oh no it's the same isn't
it it's the same the same damn it god
damn it dagnabit damn it damn it okay
it's fine alright so I don't have enough
money I just barely don't have enough
money for the puppet I don't
oh I just barely don't yeah she just
barely don't I would love to I would
love to markdown l chip hey all right
I'll chip all right whatever I think
this is the last night so I'm gonna try
I'm just gonna save my money and we're
gonna see what happens I don't know
what's gonna happen but we're gonna see
all right egg baby has no secrets I
don't know you guys I don't think I
trust any of you guys yeah I don't think
uh-huh I think you guys are all liars
just everyone the only things you guys
don't lie about is candy and that's all
it is I will do candy oh I will get
candy soon I'll get it I promise
I know that baby's a scam
obviously da da oh you need all the
certificates to get the pickles okay
alright I got you
I understand what you're getting on
about I see what you were talking about
okay all right okay all right I will get
that underway so don't you worry don't
you worry up there don't you worry about
a pretty little thing because I got that
okay
how the hell am I supposed to be able to
buy all of them that's the big question
because I don't know is there some
secret way of getting more money because
that's like I know probably if you play
if you play the right games enough you
can get more money because you can get
up to a thousand dollars every single
time if you get like a 10,000 point game
so there's got to be games that allow
you just to make money hand over fist
money money money money money
but the problem is like the liability of
some of those things don't get you sued
so then you lose money but is it worth
the money more I don't know egg baby egg
baby does not do all the things that you
guys are claiming egg baby does I'm
pretty sure I'm fairly certain egg baby
does not do the things that you are
claiming it does yeah egg baby baby
we'll get you laid I'm pretty sure baby
will not know know edit game file for
all the months I don't want a cheap god
I don't want to cheat why would I do
that get free money like baby's a scam
cheat engine
yeah I'm not I'm not gonna cheat there's
gotta be a legitimate way to get it
otherwise why would they be in the game
cuz there's got to be a legitimate way
to get what you need to get otherwise
again why would it be in the game so
that's all I have to say about that
right right okay
prai's king yeah I bet you could get but
it would be you would have to be stupid
lucky like Price King getting funtime
chica from prize king is amazing like
that's probably the only way that you
can get it if you have the luck to be
able to get funtime chica from prize
king then yeah then I would understand
if you were able to get everything that
you needed to get but I don't think I
have that it may not be Saturday wasn't
there like one buffer day I think that
was like one buffer day I don't remember
I don't remember very much it could be a
bee gives you insanity certificate I
don't think that is the thing I think
you're lying about that I'm pretty sure
your life pretty sure ah to present your
line hey we don't even have an ant I'm
trying to get the door cuz we're all
gonna die ah yes
sweet delicious visitors no one was
turned away everyone was amazed yum food
young bonus money money money
see I just don't see like if you're
doing the salvage I guess yeah I guess
if you were doing the salvage in
addition to everything else then you
could probably have another cuz the
salvage is a lot of money that is being
left on the table but I do have enough
for the puppet Oh markdown do you say
markdown you say oh that one I bet that
one's fun but how I get the figurative
puppet point now where is the security
puppet
I have to place the security puppet down
do I gonna put you right right over here
that's horrible oh I could play play
test the security puppet right oh don't
let your assign child reach the exit
your color code is green
okay not my assigned child I'm mine okay
green this is weird
hey blue ed blue no no no not me not me
not me no not mine okay all right okay
okay all right
pink okay no not mine not mine hey yeah
yeah yeah I did it I did it guys I did
it did it I did it guys did it okay your
color coat is green okay all right
ready pink no no not mine that's not my
child that's not my job that's not mine
no no no
okay
pink nah not my child not orange no no
no no Arcia
oh you're not leaving okay all right
where's uh where's the green child
where's the green one I'm what no okay
all right you're clear you're clear
you're clear okay all right okay all
right okay you guys you guys are sassy I
don't know what the hell is happening
okay
all right keep going I guess your sign
color code is green all right Green
child you ain't going nowhere
all right all right come on see if you
can slip by my watchful eye all right
let's see that's two oranges ah
twins are you all right you carry on you
you lovely lovely lovely lovely scamp's
all right anybody seen a green little
bit see the green no you're not green oh
you're not green oh you're not green
you're not green either no no no no
you're good you're good you're good
you're good you're good oh yeah you're
good you're good oh oh you're fine
you're fine you're fine now you're fine
all right all right
[Music]
No
oh hello that's not good oh oh oh geez
oh oh oh I'm in the rain oh so I oh I'm
shorting out oh that's oh that's oh oh
oh
[Music]
so the kid died of exposure and then
this animatronic went outside to try to
save the child and died in the alley
holding the child and that's
heartbreaking
that's a that's so sad would you do that
[Music]
would you do that to me what happens if
you keep playing - is there anything
that would happen if you kept play
testing oh no it's the same [ __ ] god
damn it
Jesus Jesus all right yeah I'll do candy
how about this was not your sign child
I've been goof I've groove something
good God Wow
all right candy cadet you're up I am the
candy cadet come and get your candy here
I have candy all day every day candy
candy yeah yeah that kid probably became
the puppy that's that's probably like
returns to be learned and maybe I will
tell you a story it's so weird
god there's so many just kids dying in
this entire storyline they're just
sorted dead kids now maybe there's not
so many maybe it's just the story of the
same kid dying over and over and over
yeah I have day yeah I know lefties the
puppy yeah I know that candy go return
to candy cadet again and maybe I will
tell you a story
I know candy candy cadet is here to help
candy cadet come on here can they have
candy all day every day all day every
day candy candy man we're getting like
it's getting it's getting heavy
like that's the thing about these
stories is like sometimes get like a
cadet again and maybe I will tell I
don't even know yeah it's weird
also candy cadet is a sack of [ __ ] candy
cadets never gonna give me anything
handy and I don't think there's any like
I don't think the games been out long
enough for people like totally pieced
together absolutely every way to get
every secret so it's like this is a lot
of exploration give it return to candy
cadet again and maybe I will tell you a
story yeah I've actually lost out on a
lot of money by trying to go for candy
cadet this is my last joke anything ever
I have candy okay if you don't do
anything candy cadet I will I'm gonna
destroy you I promise you that I pray
you returned to Kelly cadet again maybe
maybe you can shove it up your Robo ass
maybe you could do that maybe you could
do that alright well what else can we
buy we've only got 60 300 I don't know
if there's actually anything that we can
buy still you'll get a floor you could
get a nice floor that'd be nice
still can't get still can't get the
pickles I want those pickles I've wanted
one apparently
all right floor hey we got it floor hey
guys look we got a nice floor look
there's confetti on the floor now that
was worth $5,000 right yeah definitely
all right okay anyway yeah this was this
is not worth the time all right we're
gonna we're gonna go and do it okay I
don't know I don't know what kind of
ending we're gonna get probably a bad
ending oh man yeah I've tried it 10
times I've tried it 10 times on I've
tried it 10 times on candy cadet in a
row it doesn't work that way it's I just
don't think it's guaranteed okay that's
the only thing about it oh let me just
buy this equipment why not find out what
we're gonna get I don't know what it's
gonna be but I bet it's gonna be fun and
fresh and happy and friendly yeah oh
well anyway this isn't gonna be the end
of the stream once I get to this one I
am gonna keep going and I'm gonna start
again at least one more time and I'm
gonna try a completely different Avenue
about things we've gotten some of the
secrets for the items but I think in the
next one I need to just go for the most
money possible because if I can get
those pickles then I'm gonna be happy
and life is gonna be worth living but if
I can't get the pickles then I'm gonna
just go on a rampage make some
animatronics and then you destroy the
world
Oh God turn off the computer then hold Z
I don't think
it did nothing it did nothing it did
nothing you're just attention just a
turn if dice joy whatever it's fine okay
so we just gotta get through this see
the ending and then we're gonna go a
different strategy where I just try to
get as much money as possible which just
means that I have to get everything
everything cuz I got to get all the
money I gotta get all that money I gotta
get that money I gotta get that money if
I don't get that money I ain't gonna
give the pickles weight is weight is
pickles from buying everything or as
pickles from getting all the
certificates that's what I got to know
it's one thing is one thing and the
other thing is the other thing and we
can get all the certificates then I'm
gonna be happy I'm happy
yeah go bankrupt
and want to go bankrupt I guess I could
that is that is another way to end the
game
oh yeah I guess I guess the ways to end
the game is yeah the money or I did what
I did I got the quote-unquote good
ending the the true ending if you will
with my playthrough um you get the the
no money ending I wonder if the is there
like a is there an ending it what if I
just don't do anything like I don't buy
anything and I never place anything in
my barren nothing absolutely nothing in
my restaurant I don't take any
sponsorships I take nothing I do nothing
what if I knew there you go I want to
try that I know I know
yeah oh yeah I want to try that just
like nothing
I want to get that all right I'm gonna
do that after this cuz it's gonna reach
the end of this whatever this is I might
get another certificate but let's see
what do speedrun ending I don't think
that's a thing that can't there can't be
yeah that's another ending but it is
yeah yeah I didn't do [ __ ] whoa
congratulations on completing the week
unfortunately you did not meet your
special obligations under paragraph 4
your employment is terminated we'll mail
you your things in tape oh well hmm ah
thank you he'll pee okay what hey I am
the Lord keeper what is what does that
mean I don't think I got that
certificate from the ending I got I
think wait okay all right I'm gonna try
new game I'm gonna buy nothing I'm gonna
buy nothing but I got the Lord keeper
it's a shut up shut up shut up I'm not
gonna buy shop just up shut up shut up
shut up shut up shut up let's see how
much cash you had leftover after
purchasing your franchise package no
great that should be more than enough
now let's get started there we go left
no product catalogs nope to see your
restaurant is now officially I got all
the Lord
so I apparently I got all the lore so
does that mean I unlocked all the
secrets but I didn't get all the stories
but apparently I did but I didn't get
the stories thought apparently
but it didn't be the stories okay I know
there's an ending that has to do with
like the graveyard but I'm not sure I'm
not sure how to get that one how do you
get the graveyard ending cuz I know
that's an ending I absolutely know
that's that that is an ending because
I've seen pictures of it how do you do
that how do you do it
certificate of mediocracy is that what
I'm about to get I bet it is I bet it is
mediocrity come on there we go all right
candy at all what don't do all the tasks
well I did the test
Oh lor masters for doing the puppet that
makes me that makes more sense
you missed the secret in the car game no
I got the car game I did the car game
thing I did the car game oh it's oh the
graveyard is part of the card game Oh
what if you go back to the car game
multiple times that might be it but I'll
get that after I get really lazy I just
got to sit through these screens here oh
yeah
graveyard is in the car I'll take four
for the secret ending oh okay
all right then Blanca Blanca Blanca do I
really want to go through all this to do
the lazy ending I really do actually but
it's like it takes like five minutes to
do this
every night it's just gonna take like 30
minutes in total just to unclog the
toilets clean the ovens replace the
balls why can't I just log off and get
the [ __ ] out of here I just want to
leave stop talking about that baby
just stop turn off the car turn off the
computer and do what now and what do
what now what huh
my [ __ ] hmm trending plus lore what
get the insanity ending you guys I can't
even understand you chats going by too
fast just can't do it I got turn on
subscriber only chat if but that's not
an option that wouldn't matter anybody
pretty much everybody here is a
subscriber anyway so what is it god
subscriber Ola chat with your dick did
leave this now let's just focus on
getting you through your first week no
na and go do that get egg babies stop
talking about egg don't want egg baby
graduations on completing your first day
I don't know if there's gonna be worth
it but I'm just so I'm so goddamn
committed to this new visitors 28 total
losers 23rd revenue I can't even sued
plaintiff parents
hereby complains against defendant
fazbear entertainment young girl was
utterly and are horrific ly disfigured
by reckless endangerment exhibited by
defendant fazbear entertainment there
was nothing there her index finger was
broken due to the establishments failure
to install and improve safety
apparatuses there but for the callous
indifference fazbear entertainment inks
as shown to the safety standards her
digits would all be intact and the
spider could go up the spout again
I did
I can old leave I can't ah [ __ ]
you gave it your best shot you went all
in you put all your eggs into one basket
and did the unthinkable you ran out of
cash
we encourage entrepreneurs to follow
their dreams we also recognize a lost
cause when we see one there are no
do-overs and we trust that you know your
way out but before you go take this
certificate of bankruptcy
now do everyone a favor and get lost oh
[ __ ] just close the game oh good
maybe that's telling me something maybe
that's telling me something I think I
think I think that's telling me that
I've done the best I can and that's
probably the best place to end this so
I'm gonna end this dream here I know
frankly I honestly the it would take way
too long and I got I got I got a lot of
recording to do today so I'm gonna get
to that but thank you everybody so much
for watching I'm gonna try to get an
episode of getting over it up today you
will see I've been getting better at it
and it's been great so after this I will
get an episode of getting over it up and
that'll be super fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down the comments
below and if you want to see more cool
videos where I failed to do what I set
out to do I've got so many videos check
about playlists or all organized go to
my jail what not I don't even care just
go see some cool stuff and check out the
real playthrough so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]